doing the pitching for the tigers will
be 29 year old righty jose urania his
record this year two and seven
two out nobody on no score top of the
first julie guriel nevada hitting 328
that's third in the al
julie guriel swings and hits a fly ball
right center field daz cameron in toward
right center shallow he and badou almost
come out
luis garcia gets the ball for the astros
tonight five and four 2.82 era in 14
games 12 starts 70 in the third innings
53 hits 22 walks akeel badu left-handed
hitting center fielder leads it off
they've got the shift on for him
wait's on a 2-1
hits it and beats the shift
you go young man 11 game hitting streak
here's grossman the left fielder
former astro and houston native switch
hitter batting from the left side
waiting for a 3-0 here it is and
grossman hits it in the air out to left
center field to his right straw he calls
off brantley and straw puts it away cap
high to retire the side
lead off hit but that's all for detroit
and after one astros nothing tigers now
and the bases are loaded
for martine maldonado who has one grand
slam this year
one two
and that's driven down the left field
line and that'll drop in front of
grossman for a base hit correa scores
right behind him is toro in the second
base goes garcia two-run single for
maldonado two to nothing astros that
brings up miles straw
only a couple of home runs but they both
come this month he's again one of the
many astros hitters i couldn't find one
who wasn't in a good streak right now
he's having a good month the 2-1 ground
ball softly the short harold castro
fields a big hop underhand flip to
willie castro
they get the force on maldonado at
second but the error by willie castro
opens the door for a two-run inning we
go to the bottom of the second no more
mazzara the d-8 stands in hitting 200
273 on base percentage three homers 15
rbi
the one-two
breaking ball drops in for strike three
and mazzara goes down looking first
strikeout for garcia two out and nobody
on for daz cameron
right-handed hitting outfielder batting
242 in nine games
eight for 33 has three homers and has
driven in eight
three two
swing and a miss got him to chase a
cutter down and away back to back
strikeouts for luis garcia and it's a
one two three inning
we're through two
astros two
tigers nothing alvarez
oh for one nobody out the asteroids lead
two nothing here in the third here's the
0-1
and that's a tapper right side of the
infield coming in for the first baseman
scope and they'll have to go to second
on the fielder's choice and brantley's
gonna score and it's three nothing
so fielder's choice for alvarez knocks
in a run is 43rd
the astros have a three-run lead the
tigers and jose arena in real trouble
now here's toro
bases are loaded alvarez on third correa
on second tucker on first
and it hit him toro got hit and that's
going to be a run on o2
arena hit toro
somewhere up by the right shoulder
and that's going to drive in a run
10th rbi of the season for toro and the
astros lead 4-nothing robel garcia at
the plate
not much of a threat the 3-2
swinging a shot off the glove of scope
caught by castro throw to second and
they couldn't double them off never seen
that before all right a line drive
that went in and out of the glove of
scope and was caught in the air by
castro and a little hesitation
but they almost doubled off tucker at
second base
that was a frozen rope but you're right
i don't think i've seen that before
either i'm with you dad
maldonado a two-run single back in the
second astros lead four nothing with two
outs the two two swinging to miss
fastball got him another long inning
there's eric haas and the pitch breaking
ball did he go looked like he did did he
go
yes he did haas down on strikes
and that's the third strikeout
now for garcia
badu has the lone tigers hit so far
tonight
they had him shifted on that single and
he beat it
drives one into the right field corner
he'll beat it again
[Applause]
that's an rbi double for akil badu and
he puts the tigers on the board
another hot hitter jonathan scope but
this
company he's keeping four highest ops
leaders for players 22 years
old or younger
number one's vladimir
guerrero jr
next is fernando tattis jr then it's
badou then it's soto
he's right in the middle of some studs
there's a pop-up right side of the
infield now foul territory guriel
lopes over and he'll make the catch
for out number three here's guerrielle
ground ball fair ball down the left
field line there we go there's another
two strike hit for julie guriel scoring
miles strong it's now five to one
there's correa he's walked and singled
so far has a run scored
there's a ball rocketed past the
shortstop harold castro rbi single
carlos correa it's now six to one
nevada will be harold castro their
shortstop who walked back in the third
inning and came around to score the
tigers only run so far
here it is
it's a grounder to the right side and
it's a dive to his right for guriel he's
got it under hands to garcia cover in
the bag and he's out
great play by julie guriel
and the astros sneak out of it here in
the fourth inning it was bases loaded
and one out nobody
scores will go to the fifth in detroit
the astros with the 6-1 lead
so the bases remain loaded for correa
who has reached all three times
in the air right field following quickly
that's going to be down for a hit two
runs will score carlos
two out base hit to right field the
astros now lead this game eight to one
and jonathan scope will come to the
plateau over two tonight with a foul out
and a fly-out
right-hander delivers and scope hits it
in the air pretty deep to left field
going back on it brandly at the wall he
leaps and he makes the catch michael
brantley just took away a two-run homer
from jonathan scope left over the wall
that chain-link fence in front of the
bullpens and took away a two-run blast
inning over
and that leaves it up to daz cameron
waiting in a 2-2
on the way
swinging a fly ball softly into left
field will it drop correa al brantly in
and that's going to drop in between them
cameron on his way to second throw not
in time
boy legged out
little bloop it was in the air a long
time and daz cameron
a double scores robbie grossman and the
tigers trail 8-2 as harold castro stands
in 2-2 to castro swing and a mess chased
the breaking ball in the dirt and the
inning draws to a close tigers get a run
on cameron's rbi double but he stranded
at third base
and after six innings in detroit astros
eight tigers two
jordan comes up with bases loaded again
here's a 3-1
and alvarez hits it in the air pretty
deep to left center field going back is
grossman looking up see you later
a grand slam for jordan alvarez into the
astros bullpen and the astros lead it
12-2
runners at the corners one out for
willie castro castro for three tonight
another one-two
face hit to center
it's an rbi single for willy castro dez
cameron scores
now 12-3 and to kill the dew
who has been hitting everything on the
nose comes to the plate he's three for
four
now the two one
and that's hit hard diving to his left
toro he feels shovels the second to get
the force excellent play by abraham toro
carlos correa receiving the throw so the
tigers down to their final out with
runners at the corners for jonathan
scope who is over four tonight one
strike away
swinging a miss astros win 12-3 they
have now won 11 in a row one off their
franchise mark